Hello Internet,
Here we are: 500,000 subscribers -- well,
actually... by the time I finished this video
it's a bit more than that -- but who knew
that after I promised to do a Q&A that the
pope would resign?
Anyway...
When I uploaded my first explanation video
just over two years ago now, I would never
have expented this: over half a million subscribers
and 16 videos with over a million views. Who
knew rapidly spoken educational videos could
be so popular?
Thank you, Internet.
Now, as promised -- though slighly behind
schedule -- it's time to answer some of your
questions.
## "What's your educational background?" Rodrigo,
Campo Grande, Brazil
I went to school in New York where I earned
two college degrees, one in physics and one
in sociology. After that I moved to London
and earned a PGCE in Science Education, and
became a qualified physics teacher in England.
## "How long does it take to create a video?"
Tracey, Ohio
I've tracked my time to get an accurate answer
and every minute of final video you see takes
me between 10 and 20 hours of writing and
animating to make. So a typical 5 minute video
is 50 to 100 hours of work.
While that's a lot, it doesn't include the
research phase which is difficult to quantify
-- some of the videos I've made I'd been collecting
notes on for more than a year before starting.
## "What was you favourite video make?" Brittany
P, UK
The 2012 video was the most fun by far -- mainly
because I didn't have to do a lot of complicated
research and I got to complain about things
I don't like.
## "What change would you make to the education
system?" Lumbajack Gangsta, Austin, TX
Instead of grouping kids by age, I'd group
try grouping them by ability instead.
The idea that just because a kid is 14-years-old
they're ready for trigonometry is weird. No
other part of human society oranizes itself
this way and for good reason: it artificially
slows down the best and brightest.
## "What is do you think should be in the
curriculum but isn't?" Jamaal, Arizona
Computer programming. I was kind of shocked
and horrified when I started teaching in the
UK to discover there were no real computer
programming lessons.
Of course, there are only so many classes
in the day, and everyone wants their pet subject
taught in schools, so the equally important
question is what to get rid of to make room
for computer programming and, without the
slightest hesitation I'd ditch the foreign
languages classes -- after all, computer programming
is getting us closer and closer to a universal
translator anyway.
## "What do you do when you receive pennies?"
johnjac, Owasso
I die a little inside thinking about how political
systems can distribute tiny costs across large
numbers of people to the benefit of a few.
## "What's your favorite element?" Rasmus,
Denmark
I don't have a favorite but I'm irrationaly
fond of Tungsten mainly because my wedding
ring is made out of it.
## "What's the story behind your logo?" Joshua
B.
It's basically a personal flag for my love
of science and technology.
When I first started this channel, I thought
that I would make videos mostly about those
two things, but for various reasons, that
hasn't happened yet.
And besides, it's not like there's a shortage
of good science channels on YouTube.
By the way, If you really like the logo, you
can get it on T-Shirts and now coffee mugs
-- which is particularly appropriate as coffee
is the fuel that without which these videos
could not be made.
## "What do you do in your free time?" Sam
L, Higginsville, MO
I like to horseback ride through the mountains.
Nah, it's mostly just reddit.
Speaking of which...
## "Would you rather fight 100 duck-sized
horses or 1 horse-sized duck?" techtakular,
Alex, va
One horse-sized duck. The cube-squared law
means the legs of a horse-sized duck probably
wouldn't be structually sound. Easy fight.
## "Are there going to be more "politics in
the animal kingdom" videos?" Oli
Yes, I'm sorry, I know this playlist is unfinished
and, if any of the videos videos I've ever
made can be said to be important, it's these.
I promise at least one more about the single
transferable vote, but I don't make any promises
about when that will happen.
## "Do you think third parties will ever gain
ground in the United States?" Kerl, Florida
No.
The problem isn't politics or voter apathy,
it's the system that creates the politics
and voter apathy.
The US election system is pretty much the
worst in the civilized world -- often voting
for a 3rd party isn't just a waste it's also
a vote *against* your own best interests.
3rd parties really can't thrive under those
conditions.
## "What's one technology you wish to see
before you die?" zigonick, MO, USA
Immortality technology.
## Where do you get your ideas?
It's been my experience that creative projects
are self-sustaining. The more you write, the
more things you want to write about and the
more you program the more programming ideas
you have.
For me each video spawns more videos. The
daylight saving one, for example, originally
contained spots for information about longitude
and time zones and the seasons that got cut
but will probably become their own videos
at some point.
Also, I listen to a monstrous number of audiobooks
and podcasts. If you're interested, you can
see some of my favorites here. These help
me keep in touch with the wider world and
expose me to ideas and information that I
would not have come across on my own.
## "If you could live at any time in history
when would it be?" Bonnie, Scotland
I wouldn't.
Allow me to summarieze all of human existance
with this single graph.
## "What's the best way be successful on YouTube?"
Joe Kowalski, 44074
Make videos people want to watch.
I'm not trying to be glib here but when asked
this question I see many YouTubers talk about
the importance of upload schedules and managing
your social media and colloborations, and
my experience says that's completely backwards.
If your videos aren't interesting, no one
will care that you upload them regularly.
And twitter followers don't get you views,
views get you twitter followers and people
who want to collaborate with you.
I know it's not very helpful advice, but it's
the most truthful advice I can give.
## "What is the most interesting fact you've
ever been told." Stu1278, England
It's difficult to pick just one from an entire
lifetime, but last year Veritasium visited
me in London and walked me thorugh the process
by which trees get water from their roots
to their leaves.
That sounds really boring but it was one of
the most mind-blowing conversations I've had
in a long time.
## "How often do you engage with profesionals
while you research?" theLarom, Washington,
DC
For me, being confused and frustrated with
a topic is a vital part of figuring out how
to explain it to others so I'd say 95% of
research I do on my own.
If I'm really out of my depth on a topic -- like
the debt video and the pope video -- I try
very hard to find an expert to look over the
final draft of my script but time constraints
and finding trustworthy experts is sometimes
a bit difficult.
## "What is your favorite internal organ?"
trint99, DFW, TX
The Brain -- because it's the one that's me.
## "Is there any part of science do you want
to be proven wrong?" Jrod N, Massacusetts
Yes, the current interpretations of the ultimate
fate of The Universe all make me sad.
## "Can you answer 10 questions in under 30
seconds?" YouReadMeName
## 1: "What is your favorite scientific study
ever published?" Marie, Reno, NV
Unskilled Are Unaware: Further Explorations
of (Absent)
Self-Insight Among the Incompetent
Link in the description.
## 2: "Hogwarts house?" Zeinoun Awad, Lebanon
Ravenclaw. (I'd hope)
## 3: "Celsius or Fahrenheit?" Kubez
Fahrenheit.
##4: Kirk or Picard
Picard.
## 5: "Do you wear glasses?" Spartacus McFancy
Pants
Uh, yeah.
## 6: "Favorite empire?" Caleb Glickman, USA
The second one. Those monks were awesome.
## 7: "How can a country be totally self sufficient
-- as in no imports or exports?" Amberjack1973
Simple, resort to a midevil level of technology.
## 8: "Favourite sport?" soccernhlfan, Canada
No.
## 9: "Should science play a bigger role in
politics?" Dip, London, UK
What, you mean the method by which we determine
truth? Yeah, I think it should.
## 10: "Can you answer 10 questions in under
30 seconds?" YouReadMeName
Apparently.
Alright, thanks to everyone who submitted
questions -- it's been fun, Internet.